un mandat de président de la république
se joue dans les premières heures et
c'est une règle à laquelle je ne connais
pas d'exception c'est l'année de la plus
forte légitimité d'un président de la
république n'a t'il que 100 jours pour
faire ses preuves l'état de grâce est
elle un concept purement médiatique
c'est de gaulle d'amore président du
conseil qui va installer cette idée de
rythme intense au début du mandat il
comprend très vite que cette période est
cruciale pour marquer les esprits
imposer un style rupture une autorité et
c'est ce que feront tous ses successeurs
tous sans exception pour pompidou la
priorité sera bien sûr de se démarquer
de l'image du général d'exister par lui
même aux yeux des français il se
montrera plus détendu plus naturel moins
solennelle valéry giscard d'estaing
bousculera l'école lui aussi ses
premiers actes politiques forts seront
sociétaux c'est lui qui va ouvrir le
gouvernement aux femmes et à la société
civile lui aussi qui va très vite
abaisser la majorité et donc le droit de
vote à 18 ans les cent jours seront
aussi très marquant chez mitterrand en
81 le premier président socialiste de la
vème république doit absolument imprimer
la marque d'un pouvoir de gauche hausse
du smic hausse des allocations
familiales du minimum vieillesse
cinquième semaine de congés payés
semaine de 39 heures mitterrand savait
que l'état de grâce ne durait pas
longtemps jacques chirac aussi ses deux
mandats seront marquées par des actions
fortes le premier avec la reprise
assumer mais impopulaire des essais
nucléaires le second avec la création
des contrats jeunes et le nom à une
intervention en irak avec nicolas
sarkozy le rythme s'intensifie encore
toutes les réformes à la fois tout tout
de suite tout le temps ces mots d'ordre
je dis à mon équipe
on a suscité un grand espoir vous mettez
au boulot maintenant si vous arrêtez pas
ça va aller vite on commence à fond et
on accélère françois hollande lui
calmera ce rythme peut-être même un peu
trop l'ancien président le dit lui même
dans le film il regrette de ne pas avoir
commencé tout de suite les débats au
parlement sur le mariage pour tous quant
à emmanuel macron ses 100 premiers jours
seront marqués par la fin de l' isf par
la réduction des contrats aidés par la
baise les apl et cela façonnera a
d'ailleurs son image jusqu'à la fin de
son premier mandat peut-être la preuve
alors que les premières actions
politiques d'un président sont bel et
bien crucial pour suite c'est toute la
problématique abordée dans ce
documentaire 100 jours de patrice
duhamel et de gabriel le bomin avoir ce
samedi à 21h sur public sénat